missy how would you and sheldon like a
graduation party
why would missy have a graduation party
because i'm graduating elementary school
that counts of course it can yes it's a
big deal
she's going to a new school new friends
new teachers
same clothes because we're poor we're
not poor
so i can get new clothes not rich either
do i really gotta sit through two
graduations
yes it is a special day for your brother
and your sister
i'm giving the valedictorian speech and
i'm singing this land is your land with
a bunch of other kids
and we are proud of you both equally
guess what
the local news wants to do a story on
children being valedictorian
isn't that great
what me and my family which may sound
impressive but this is the same local
news that covered a potato chip
shaped like texas so act natural we're
just having a chat i'm going to ask you
all a few questions about sheldon's high
school
graduation i'm graduating also really
you're graduating from high school too
no elementary school
oh my class is singing this land is your
land
wanna hear it this land is your land
this land
can i ask my girlfriend to the prom on
tv it would blow her mind
[Music]
the following day i attended my sister's
elementary school graduation
she didn't deliver a speech to me but
she did make eye contact while she sang
this land is your land
later that day we had a graduation party
for me and my sister
i don't normally care for parties but
this one wasn't so bad
who's ready for cake me
hey should we say grace heck yeah
let's hold hands oh cool let's say grace
dale invited jesus to the party and
while he wasn't on my guest list
it was okay because it made my mom happy
in fact it was the best graduation party
i had ever been to
until the one we had for my son leonard
cooper
amen i wanted his name to be leonard
nimoy
cooper but amy wouldn't let me be happy
i let you name him leonard
okay okay love you
[Music]